foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I was curious uh Mike Francesca's take
on this the radio Hall of Famer he took
the temperature of New York Sports for
quite a few decades there with Mad Dog
Russo former WFAN host and host of the
Mike Francesa podcast and that's uh bet
Rivers network you can listen to Mike
instant reactions to the biggest games
and unbiased Sports Talk each week Mike
good to have you back where do you stand
on Aaron Rodgers going to the Jets yay
folks who need to make wages because
they pay the bills
um as far as
I think the Jets want them a lot
I don't think the Packers won them at
all uh but I think he's trying
everybody's patience and let me say this
if he doesn't make an announcement today
then he can get lost I I think that he
will have worn out his time period it's
over he's captivated the city and the
media for long enough and there comes a
point where everyone just says enough
goodbye and I think he's pushing the
limit right now so hopefully he puts
this to bed today but I wonder about
this wish list that you're bringing in
these players I don't know if you bring
in objection please no you don't want
obj in a jet stream you don't want him I
can't stand them I couldn't stand him
when he was here
[Music]
the guy who will ruin every team he's on
I don't want him anywhere near the Jets
the Jets chance to be terrific and for
him to come in with a wish list of
basically guys who are on the other side
of it at best except for one I mean be
quiet come here lead quarterback cash
your big check and shut up I mean geez I
mean he's annoyed me to the point where
I really wanted him here in the worst
way because I want to watch him play
he's a brilliant quarterback as talented
the quarterback as I've ever seen but
the other stuff the baggage and all the
nonsense and the wish list and
everything else be quiet and come here
and just be the quarterback is he
overrated or over covered
he's over covered on the field he is not
overrated although
his postseason play leaves a lot to be
decided when you look at it compared to
his regular season play he has not
you look at guys and the guys we reveal
the most are the guys who if not lift
their postseason performances at least
make them equal to their regular season
performances he's not one of those uh
Peyton Manning wasn't one of those uh
Derek Jeter was one who did it the other
way and that's why he's so revered Tom
Brady same thing they were better in the
big game Joe Montana was brilliant in
the big game so those are the guys we
reveal the most and I think uh he has
been on the other side he has not been
as good in the postseason in the big
game as he's been in the regular season
where he has been the best quarterback
for a very long time what is Plan B for
the Jets uh now I don't think they have
one but let me say this I heard someone
say ones if they give up a one
considering
than the package are it would be the
worst horse trading in the history of
the NFL they should never ever give up a
one in this because the Packers have no
choice but to get rid of them if they
give up anything better than a
conditional two I think they got it
absolutely taken in the deal but I also
wonder about this Mike we're talking to
Mike Francesca that the Packers may look
at this that Rogers is asking for these
items they sign lizard if they're going
to bring in Randall Cobb Mercedes Lewis
that it feels like the Packers may have
a little leverage with them to say all
right you're down the road with him
you're going to make this deal we'd like
a little bit more from you guys prayer I
don't think I think the Packers are so
desperate to get out from under him and
his money right now that they will just
say goodbye and the deal my
understanding the deal is done
so the deal was done if the deal is done
with any number ones I think it just got
taken to the cleaners because the
packets are completely desperate and if
you notice look around there's nobody
else who wants them yeah
uh explain the the Jets history here to
people just so they get a a sense of and
you were there I mean just one word
clueless I mean there's no other word an
owner who has no idea uh hired the wrong
people set the wrong tone made the wrong
moves made the wrong deals throwing bad
luck and you have a franchise that has
been completely inept and that's what
they are Robert Sala and Aaron Rodgers
how will that marriage work
yeah yeah so they have a great defense
and they have Personnel Hall's a great
is a terrific back if he's healthy
Wilson's a wonderful receiver I'd go out
with that 13th pick and take the Notre
Dame tight end and give that Target I
think that kid's going to be a superstar
that's what I would do they go out and
get another receiver maybe draft one
maybe
an inch away they gotta buff up the
offensive line a little bit their
defense is right now as good as any
defense in the National Football League
I think that they are an inch away with
the right quarterback okay where do you
have them let's start with the AFC East
are they comparable to Buffalo if Rogers
comes there yes
Miami
better
Patriots didn't do anything in the off
season it just not even a discussion
okay now let's take it out of the AFC
East where would the Jets stand uh would
start with the uh second to Kansas City
really yes second best team in the AFC
yes with Rogers and with Rogers focused
and and understanding
what he has to do and I'm hoping that's
the case because I think Rogers still
has a lot left let's be honest he threw
a lot of passes last year that were
dropped you had a lot of guys run the
wrong routes they ran the wrong routes
all season they ran the wrong routes in
the Red Zone he was completely upset and
really terrorized by them more than
anything else uh I think he's got
everything he has
I think it could be good for three more
years minimum if he wants to do it I
really do I think he's got a lot left
that's what he wants to come here and
get this done and not be off in a tent
somewhere or worrying about Jeopardy or
whatever is on his mind I don't know the
bottom line is he comes in and I'm all
for him taking the number 12. I thought
that was a very nice move by Joe Namath
who is a wonderful person and his
gracious a superstar and Joe is his
biggest superstar as there has ever been
if you're my age Joe meant it he meant
it a good way and there's a symmetry
there from 12 50 years ago to now 12
again I like that let him wear it wear
it with pride wear it and try to take
this team and Lead it and they have the
talent to be really something special if
he is all in you can hear more of Mike
the Mike Francesa podcast from BET
Rivers network
uh well I have you are you all in on the
Knicks
uh
where they're going um not all in and I
love Brunson the hot move was perfect it
made them better it made them cohesive
it gave them a real rotation it made
them better both sides of the of both
ends of the floor they're playing really
well now the Brunson uh ankle was a bit
of a problem because it set him back a
little bit they still won on the west
coast which was good uh I think they
could go in and they could win a series
I don't think they'll go past that but
that will light up this town and the
town has bought them and brought into
them for the first time in years and the
biggest reason is Brunson his leadership
he was worth it he was worth more double
what he got that's how good he's been
he's a leader he's a winner Brian Hardin
was a great move they're there now if
they don't screw it up they have to
exchange Randall for one more really
good or top player if they can do that
because I'm not a big Randall guy and
he's terrible in the fourth quarter if
I'm if they can do that they could
finally make be challenged but right now
I think they're going to go in the
playoffs and win around
great to catch up with you Mike good
luck with the podcast and thanks for
joining us faith and Adam Sandler's
bracket I can tell you that right now
who do you have winning at all I think
Alabama is the best team and Miller is
the best of the player as long as he's
not complicit in a capital murder which
imagine we have to say that before the
tournament starts as long as he's not
complicit in a capital murder I think
they can go all the way imagine making
that statement I know I know well I
wonder how much of a storyline this
becomes Mike as Alabama progresses in
the tournament I don't know
because he's such a freakish player but
I would take Miller second I think
Miller is the closest thing that Durant
I've ever seen he is a great player
thank you Mike see you Dan thank you
that's Mike Francesa from uh bet Rivers
network the Mike Francesa podcast you
can listen to his instant reactions to
biggest games on biased Sports Talk each
week